Let me go ahead and switch up the uh I'm
put you on the big screen now. There you
go, man. Oh, you got you got that
Shakespeare, man.
>> Yeah.
>> Look like you got that knowledge on you,
bro.
>> Hey, man. Or hey, it could just be age,
you know, but yeah.
>> Okay. So, you you reject the deity of
Christ because you you believe the Bible
is explicit that he is the son of God,
which it is. The Bible is explicit that
he's the son of God. Um so, that would
mean that he's not God. Is that right?
>> He's not.
>> Would you use this? Would you use the
same logic for a son of man that Jesus
because he is explicitly identified as
the son of man that he's not man
>> because he's called the son of man that
he's not man?
>> Yeah.
>> No, he he's he was a man.
>> But he's
>> excuse me.
>> But he's the son of man,
>> right? And he was a man that was came on
this earth from birth.
>> So that so just because he's identified
as a son of man doesn't disqualify his
nature as being man. Just like Jesus
being identified as the son of God
doesn't disqualify his nature as being
God. It means he's God.
>> I would say um he's definitely not God
in the sense of like um the most high
God, right?
>> What what what what constitutes you
being the most high God?
>> The um the father, the one in control
specifically, the one in control of
everything, the the creator like
>> so he's the only most high in the Bible.
Christ was never called most high. And
Christ called Most High?
>> Yeah.
>> Mhm.
>> All right, let's go to it. Is Is it
Isaiah 9 you're speaking of?
>> No.
>> Okay, let's go to it.
>> Yeah, we'll go to Daniel 7.
>> You believe Jesus is the son of man in
Daniel 7, right?
>> Yes, sir.
>> Awesome.
>> Seven. You have like 13 specifically?
>> No.
>> Can we go to 13 as well?
>> Yeah. Yeah, we'll we'll read it all.
>> Okay.
>> Daniel Selm. All right. All right. All
right. Daniel Sel. And then I also want
to pull up the Hebrew
>> Aramaic.
>> The Hebrew Aramaic.
>> Thank you. That's what I got you for.
That's what I got you here for, man.
Let's pull up the Aramaic.
>> Ah. All right. While um while you're
pulling that up um where in Daniel 7 and
13 um where the son of man, right,
Christ is being brought to the ancient
of days, God. That's what I meant to
say. That's what I meant to say. I'm
sorry. Christ is not called the ancient
of days. That's what I meant to say. So
again in Daniel 7 and3 where the son of
god right the son of man Christ is being
brought to the ancient of days we see
that title specifically only right for
the father
>> we never see Christ being called um the
ancient of days that's specifically what
I meant to say
>> that's fine that's fine I hope I hope
you don't get it confused we make a
distinction between the person of the
son and the person of the fatherm Mhm.
>> Um we have no problem with designated
titles for either persons. That doesn't
negate the nature that the persons share
together as the one God, the most high
God. So that's what I want to show you.
I want to show you that Jesus is
identified as the most high just like
the ancient of days is.
>> Okay?
>> Right? But as I just mentioned that when
quoting Daniel 7 and 13
>> that was actually an error in my end
because when I was quoting Daniel 7 and
>> I'm not talking about verse 13
>> of days.
>> I got you. I'm not but I'm not talking
about verse 13.
>> Right. But I would say
>> I know but you said that Jesus is not
this is what you your whole standpoint
was Jesus is not the most high God.
>> Right. So,
>> so I'm about to show you that Jesus is
the most high God and then now you're
going to believe Jesus is God, right?
>> No, no, I won't. Because again, I I
literally just said I literally just
said that's not my point. My point was
about he's not called the ancient of
days. That was my point.
>> Okay. If he's the most high God, then is
he not?
>> We're dealing with most high God again.
So, let me let me say something.
>> That's what you said.
>> Wait, wait, wait. But to be fair, to be
fair, right, while you was going there,
Daniel 7 and 13 popped in my mind. And
while I was quoting it, Ancient of Dates
popped in my mind.
>> Before that, brother K,
listen, before Daniel was brought up,
>> right?
>> I asked you, remember we were talking
about son of God and son of man.
>> And so I said, "Okay, so since Jesus is
son of God, that means he's God, right?
Just like if he's son of man, he's man."
You said, "Oh, well, he's not the most
high God." And then I asked, "Okay, so
what constitutes being the most high
God?" You said, "Being in control of
everything." And you know, I was like,
"Okay." And you said, "Jesus is never
identified as the most high God."
>> That's when I said, "Yes, he is." You
said, "Show me." I then said, "Daniel
7." Then you went on to reference verse
13 and ancient of days with Most High.
Let me agree with you cuz that's that
most high stuff is not the um title I
was even looking for. So let me agree
with you on that. Originally was Daniel
7 and3 the ancient of days. Ancient of
days.
>> That was my point. So let me make a
point real quick with that. So I agree
with you with the other point. That
wasn't my point.
>> Wait, wait, wait. So you agree that
Jesus is the most high God
>> that it it calls him the most high God.
I'll agree with that.
>> Okay. So now let me let me show you
something. Look because before we go to
something this is extremely important
what you just identified that Jesus is
the most high God. Now let me give you
something man. You like you like Bible
right?
>> Yeah.
>> I like the Bible Cal.
>> Yeah I like Bible. Hey can you do me a
Can you mind grabbing my King James
Bible for me?
>> Let's get the Bible man. Let's get the
verse. Let's get the Bible. All right we
going we going we going to get we going
to get the verses. Matter of fact, let's
let's get a couple of let's get a couple
of these verses here because the only
thing we do around here is we just read.
>> Right. Right.
>> And as we're reading, here it is. As
we're reading, we like to just access
the scriptures
>> and then let me get my let me I'm going
just get them ready for you. Just bring
up that second one when you have your
debate in March.
>> If that happens,
>> that will happen.
that that he's Yeah, if that happens,
you're right. You're right. You was
right.
>> So again, while you're going to that um
real quick. So in the Daniel 7 and 13
passage where it says the son of man,
right, is being brought to the ancient
of days to the father. Like that's two
separate people right there. That's like
you
>> two distinct persons. You're absolutely
right.
>> Can you be brought to him? Right. If
you're being brought to the guests
behind you, you're obviously separate
people, right? That's what
>> not separate but distinct persons.
>> You're not the same. That's what I'm
saying. Also,
>> you're not the same person. We are not
modalists. We don't say that uh you know
the that the father, son, holy spirit
are different modes of one God. We agree
they are distinct persons. One god now
forever.
>> Right. And real quick, um this is by the
way to be specific. I'm not a Muslim.
I'm an Israelite just to be specific.
>> Okay.
>> Um, with that being said, real quick,
um, I definitely wanted to say thank you
for letting me join. And hey, um, you
was cooning for Charlie crying. You
should be ashamed of yourself, Logic.
That's a
>> If you said if you said I'm show you
what the I don't care what the tune
does.
>> Shut your mouth and open your Bible.
Shut your mouth and open your Bible. We
can't hear you no more.
>> Shut your mouth and open your Bible. Get
your Bible. your master. I already said
it.
>> Shut your dumb mouth and get your Bible
out.
>> For master.
>> Shut your dumb mouth and get your Bible
out.
>> Get your Bible out. Get your Bible out,
man. What What we doing here? Look. Look
at this coward manifesting.
>> All for matter.
>> He wants me He wants me to kick him. Now
you've been getting your butt kicked
with this Bible and you want to run. I
ain't gonna kick you. He want to run. I
ain't gonna kick you.
You trying to jump and open your Bible.
>> I can't open your Bible. Open your
Bible. Stop. Stop all that. Stop all of
that. Stop all that barking, dog. We
can't hear you. We can't hear you, dog.
Quit all that fake barking. Open your
Bible.
>> Open your Bible. You told your wife to
get your Bible, right? All right. Go to
Psalm 8. Go to Psalm 83.
>> Dancing for your master.
>> Go to Psalm 83.
>> Damn shame.
>> Look at you trying to run.
>> Look at you trying to run. Look at this
clown.
>> All right. You deserve that.
>> And you deserve this beating you're
getting.
>> You deserve that.
>> You deserve my boot down your throat.
>> Let's go ahead and get it out.
>> For he running away. Get out. Get off my
stream. You absolute coward. You're a
coward. You're an absolute coward. You
didn't want to get this rest of this
work. But I'll give I'll give it for the
audience. I'll let you sit there and
talk to yourself. Can't nobody hear you
down there. Watch this, y'all. This is
what the This is what the Bible says
here. Watch this. So, he admitted this
dummy. This dog admitted that Jesus is
the most high God stupidly enough while
trying to go against his deity. So what
does Psalms say? Who is the most high
God according to Psalms 83? Let's go
ahead and share this on the screen real
quick. That's what happens when these
dogs get exposed. They start manifesting
hoping and praying that you kick him.
Man, please. I'm going just say this
stuff so he can kick me.
>> He messed up. He messed up and he was
worried. He starting to panic there. He
ran away.
>> Had to manifest. Had to manifest. So
this is what Psalm 83:18 says. Now
remember guys, he said Jesus is the most
high God while trying to argue against
his divinity. You admit somebody's the
most high God.
>> He admitted it and then trying to say
he's not. So who is the most high God
here? It says, matter of fact, let me
just for emphasis, man.
>> It's like it dawned on him in the
middle. He's like, "Oh crap, I just
admitted and oh, let me change the
subject.
>> Now I'm in trouble. Now I'm in trouble."
Watch this, guys. Who's the most high?
It says, "That they may know that you
alone, your name is Yahweh and the most
high over all the earth." So he just
admitted that Jesus is Yahweh, the most
high God over all. Thanks for coming,
you absolute clown. We love We love your
type, man. We love your type.
>> Them Israel them Why do we even call
them Israelites?
>> Them the Mus. We call them Musbru Is
Israelites. Buzz Brews. Tom, you're on
stage.
>> Yo. Hey. How are you doing?
>> Pretty good, man. What's your religion?
>> Oh, I'm agnostic. You know, I saw like
the people always saying like it is
Islam actually that can come. I'm not
Islam. Say
>> it's like actually only Muslim person
that can come. I'm not Muslim. You know,
I am agnostic. I don't know if you know
that specific way.
>> Why are you agnostic? because you know I
think it's like um the life life in
general life action that's happened my
life basically that make me just leave
quite a bit the Christianity
>> oh so things things happened in your
life and now you don't know if God
really exists
>> so no it's like the the way that they
portray or we portray God now each
Abrahamic religion doesn't really make
sense for me just I have like one
question for you if I can ask.
>> Let's let's deal with let's deal with
the fundamental of whether you believe
God exists or not. Do you believe God
exists?
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> Okay. So So you're you believe God
exists. So you're agnostic on who the
God is.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> I watch a lot of your video and you know
actually always made a new point that
make me think of like yeah I just have
to think deeper in into Christianity.
Sorry I speak French. French is my first
languages. I don't know if you just
market. Yeah.
>> So I think you have a lot of knowledge.
So I I watch a lot of your show. But one
of my question I had nobody actually
spoke it. So that's was maybe I saw like
one day if I can have the chance to talk
to you maybe I can just send you the
question know the question.
>> Yeah. So what's what's your question
then? So I make some couple research and
I saw like the first religions was
actually either Jewish you know or
Hinduism and like thinking like how is
it possible that God want to everyone
that God want everyone going to
Christianity make like a religion like
Hinduism take place like otherware you
know or let oh Jesus could let something
like that happen you know me
>> do you understand this question
>> so you're you're let me just make sure
to clarify. So your oldest religion is
not Christianity. It's like Judaism or
Hinduism.
>> Doesn't seem like God is reaching
everyone like all those people in the
past. Is that
>> basically
>> let's just talk about like just
statistics here act. So like 98% of the
people that have existed on this planet
have come in the past 2,000 years. Like
we've had a population explosion in like
the past 300 years. So like there were
never billions of people on this planet
until like very recently. So most people
that have lived have lived very recently
to start. So we're talking about the
majority of people have come after
Christianity. The other thing to keep in
mind is um have you have you looked in
any of the anthropologists work out
there about primitive cultures and
tribes around the world?
>> Sorry. Say again. Have you looked into
any of the research on like anthropology
on looking at primitive cultures around
the world?
>> I think I'm doing my myself so I don't
know if it was the best way to do it.
But so like was Mesopotamia I think so.
>> No, I'm talking about more primitive
than Mesopotamia. Like I'm talking about
like when when scholars want to study
what the most primitive people believe,
they go to various huntergatherer tribes
that were in the Australas and Africa
and the Americas. Mhm.
>> Have you looked at any of that research
about what people like that believed?
>> No. No.
>> So in the 1800s there was a guy named
Eie Taylor and he said
>> he said cultures start out really
primitive. They start animism
>> and then they move polytheism and then
monotheism.
>> Mhm. The problem is is one of his
students pointed out, his name was
Andrew Lang, and he was getting he was
reading all the reports coming out of
Australia, the most primitive cultures,
the cultures that had the least contact
around the world, they were the most
monotheistic
believers in of these primitive
cultures. They believed in there was
this one high creator God who gave them
a moral law that they were supposed to
follow. And that has been documented um
uh in other research like Wilhelm
Schmidt continued a lot of that
research. So just to start on that I
have a video on my channel called the
case for ancient monotheism.
>> The case for ancient monotheism. I cover
a lot of that. Now let's go to the
Bible.
>> What does God say in the Bible about
this? Well, if you go to places like
Acts 17:30, he says, "In the past, God
overlooked times of ignorance, but now
he calls all men to repent." So, in
Christianity, we believe this. God is
perfectly just.
>> He is perfectly loving.
>> If he is perfectly just and loving, he
will know how to judge people in the
past who never heard of Christ. And
there, this is implied in the
scriptures. He said he's going to
overlook ignorance. It's not going to
count against them on judgment day.
They'll be judged based on the knowledge
or the information they had. That's in
Acts 17:30. So
>> that's what that that's gives you kind
of like a kind of like a rough
>> look at everything there.
>> But is it that fair actually that people
that make like some sin in the past
because they didn't know Christ like
actually nothing is going to happen to
them. But us you know ourel right now
living in the 21st century because we
know Jesus if we make it the same sin as
them or centers will be different. Is it
that really fair because I know that God
is fair you know so that also see some
point cannot really
>> well it is fair you know
>> it would be fair because our
circumstances are different uh it's like
it's like you know example of like if I
were to you know use a knife to harm
someone I know better and so therefore
I'm going to be judged based on those
circumstances and knowledge. If a
three-year-old does it, they're not
going to be judged with the same
standard. And therefore, it is fair
because God is taking into account the
knowledge they had, the circumstances to
judge properly. So what is the criteria
of God for actually revealed the self
because you think like right now they're
ready and before they are not you know
like oh he judged the fact that right
now we are ready but before we we was
not we were not you know don't know if
make it sense because you told like it
depends on the circumstance so the
circumstance before like we wasn't
actually we were actually ready but
right now God reveal itself because we
are ready you know So all we he can
actually know that we are ready right
now.
>> What do you mean?
>> It makes sense.
>> Do you mean we're ready as a culture or
individually?
>> Like for him revealing right now and not
before you know why
>> when he came as Jesus and revealed
himself to the world that way.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Why right now and not
before you know?
>> Yeah. Good question. So this has been
pointed out by scholars. At that time uh
it was very it was very optimal for God
to reveal himself. The world had been
conquered by the Grecoman culture. So
they had mass languages being spoken.
Greek and Latin, Latin in the west, uh
Greek in the east, the roads had been
built. So Paul is able to go from city
to city spreading the gospel and it
spreads like wildfire. I mean prior to
that, prior to this this whole this
empire building, it was a lot harder to
travel terms of information. Rome Rome
came in when Rome came into Judea, it
was the place was covered in bandits. it
was very hard to travel. They cleaned a
lot of that up. This made this so much
easier for the gospel to spread and then
grow. And again, as I said, most people
who have existed on this planet have
existed after Jesus, not prior.
>> Okay. Interesting. Okay. I never saw
something like that. I never had that
agreement. I have another point, you
know, I saw that I want to to talk if
it's okay for you. Like I'm really
thankful for all the time that you just
giving. I another question. It's cool.
>> Okay.
>> So, I heard like one tribes. I don't
know if you know of them is ASDA.
>> Aztec. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Asda. So in Tanzania, you
know, like when I see like some studio
of them is like one or three children
dying from infanticide. I don't know if
it's saying like that in English like
they dying as a stranger children, you
know. And I'm thinking like because they
don't have like the advanced medicine
that especially in Europe or yourself or
you're in America you have or we have
they dying you know as a children you
know and I'm thinking like oh how is it
possible that a lovely god just let
something like that happen you know
>> lets people die of disease before modern
medicine. Yeah, especially that tribe,
you know, because they sorry if I'm was
born like there, you know, I I cannot
get the same vaccine that we have here
in Europe
>> or in in America for you.
>> So, I wouldn't, you know, be alive. You
know what I mean?
>> Yeah. So you're you're diving into the
the the problem of evil uh and how we
deal with this uh
>> especially this is no because
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. This is I think like sometime this
is not really the same as evil because I
can make some bad action but I didn't I
choose to make the bad action but I
didn't choose to have like a real bad
affection you know.
>> Yeah. So this this is a very long answer
I could give. Uh how much time do I got
Avery? How you may give a short answer
quick answer? You can do whatever you
brother.
>> Yeah. Here's here's what I would say is
that there's a lot of assumptions that
go into this that we are already
assuming. For one of the things you
we're assuming is that
>> the nor what is actually good for God to
do is for him to reduce suffering and to
increase well-being or pleasure. This is
a a normative assumption that we have in
terms of how we do ethics. And what
Christians say is that's not ethics.
Ethics is much broader than that. God is
maintained by like a virtue ethical uh
uh system. That is what Christianity
teaches. So what God's goals are is his
goals are going to be to increase virtue
and decrease sin, decrease vice and
well-being and pleasure. Those are
things that come after virtue has been
maximized.
>> So that is what we argued. So right now,
God with humanity in our sinful state,
he is trying to make us more virtuous.
And here's the problem. Here's the
problem I pointed out before. You can't
maximize virtue in a state where there
are no challenges. So there are things
to overcome and there are processes that
we go through because you can't
experience courage if there's nothing to
be afraid of. You can't experience the
the virtue of compassion if no one has
suffered. So if God is maximizing
virtue, he creates a free world where we
are free and there is suffering involved
and there is challenges so that they can
be overcome. The difference is that we
also add that is in scripture God
promises this is a momentary affliction
preparing us for the weight of glory
that we will eventually be made whole
like Jesus and then he will wipe away
every tear and there will be no pain or
death for suffering has passed on. So
because we are fallen because we are
sinful God allows suffering in this
world so that it can counterbalance us
and allow us to challenge against it to
increase in our virtues. And again, I
have another, if you want more details,
I have a video on my channel called the
problem of suffering a Christian
response where I go into that in a lot
more detail.
>> Okay. I think my son is interesting. I
don't really have the dance road that I
was looking for to be honest, but it's
like a a different analysis, a different
thing that you actually answer, but it
could be so interesting
>> and Yeah. Yeah. because I saw also like
a another pawn that I don't know if you
already saw that before. It was like a
because I know you told me that majority
of people went um
they they came to life after you know
the Jesus you know
>> I saw like in ancient Turka an ancient
Turka
>> don't know if you said something like
that
>> Turkey
>> yeah they have like some temple there
you know
>> so I was thinking like they already have
some kind of um link to the divine you
know to actually divine talking of
Goblate. Uh it's a it's an ancient site
where they were doing something there,
but scholars are debating about what was
going on there. And again, we wouldn't
say that uh we wouldn't say that they
didn't have any connection or access to
the the divine. We're not entirely sure
what was going on at those sites.
>> Uh it's so far in the past, these were
hunter gatherers and it's it's totally
up for debate right now. So this we we
don't know entirely what they believed
or what was going on. There's a whole
plethora of scholarly opinions on that.
>> Yeah. Okay. Because I was thinking the
same question like, oh, is it possible
that like the same girl, you know, can
let something like that happening? But
>> well, check out check out the video I
did the case for ancient monotheism. And
you're going to see a lot of evidence
for ancient monotheistic beliefs.
>> Okay. Okay. Makes sense.
>> Go to guy for this stuff, man. That's
what I do.
>> I make a make a video library all this
stuff.
>> Yeah. So also some of your videos too
maybe I think like it was with every you
know preaching and stuff like that.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh I love your your
knowledge and all of that you know
there's always something interesting
>> and because I was approached recently by
some Muslim I was always like I like
every face in my head where they was
talking I was like okay
am I going to take them serious or not?
They was really nice. They were in like
a commercial way you know. So that's why
I was thinking like something is maybe
behind all of that. So that was all
always my questioning know but it's
always because of the practice that I
had like done on Jesus in general you
know
>> even like today you know what's happened
with Charlie and stuff like that it's
like oh is it possible like as a god
lovely god especially with Charlie you
know that was talking a lot about god
kid oh we can just let something like
that happen you know just talking really
honestly that was always my question
it's not really about the what the
teaching because the teaching is up to
me something is really good. And um like
Charlie too helped me because he said he
said like some once forget all the
divine um thinking of the Bible just put
the teaching in your life you're going
to see like your life getting better and
that's actually what I've done
>> it's still today um I would love to say
thank you you know because it really
helped me on a lot of point you know
>> like English I was learning it for it's
like a three or four month I'm learning
English so my English is not really that
grace but can be understood right now.
So I'm really thankful of all these
teaching that he had because it's
actually this teaching that came to me
you know.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Interesting.
>> You you hold on to the teachings of
Jesus man and you won't you won't
>> you won't be able to deny uh how he
really affects your life because his
teachings are alive and and relevant for
every time all time never outdated
>> you know. So,
>> and try try to find try to find a good
church where you're you're at that can
help you grow. You can talk more about
with local believers about this stuff as
well. Having a a local church family is
very helpful for this kind of stuff
>> because except to me like I love to
read. I love to learn about you all
because my church and stuff like that
like we we congalles and we Europeans.
So it's like an another way of thinking
you know because you know here in um our
country we come straight from Congo
straight from Ghana from P from African
country you know so it's like a
different mindset so they really like if
you doubt don't try to doubt it is the
truth you know
>> and the difference with you is like when
somebody doubt you say like say you do I
cannot bring the answer you know so it's
something that's really different but
like I had like some some problem to to
believe like the Adam and Eve story. I
don't know if we can talk about that.
It's not really related to God.
>> Yeah. And uh well, I got to bring up the
next few guesses, brother. But
>> go to my channel. I got a Genesis 1 to11
series. I I go through I have a video on
like each chapter and I just go through
it one at a time. We explain Adam and
Eve and everything in that.
>> Okay. Introducing
>> Yep. Inspiring philosophy, man. That's
his channel. It's tag it's tagged in the
uh it's tagged if you don't already have
it.
>> I will add I will definitely add for it.
Thank you for all your time. You know,
>> it was really nice to talk to you. Take
care, man.